I wanted to think I'm not going crazy
like I'm doing all this press around the
world for the first few years I've been
involved in things before and I know
when something's popular and this felt
incredibly popular but it didn't feel
like Fox ever recognized that for
whatever reason I don't know um but it
was popular and then it just grew and
grew once it went on Netflix it just
exploded were you the one who told the
rest of the cast or they already knew uh
I so people have been calling me saying
do you know what's going on do you know
what's going on and I said Amy yeah
Amy I just tell Amy then she tell
everyone else um I and I was basically
like look I Warner Brothers are trying
to find a new home for it that's what I
know and as soon as I know anything else
I'll let you know but until then just
keep you know keep plugging away keep
responding on Twitter keep telling
people to keep the faith as it were um
you know we're not going down we're not
going to just lie down and take it sort
of thing um that's beautiful just never
happens yeah and and again you know I've
been told by Peter Roth and other people
this never happens this never happens
this never happens but that weird sort
of feeling that you were talking about
before about your career and the same
thing that I'd had I'd had this kind of
nigle that something was going to happen
about it and and it did you
know I'll bring this back to
me um I had a show that got cancelled in
two seasons and and the ratings if they
were now it would have been a big show M
like the ratings were pretty good they
were decent they weren't you know but
now if we had those ratings that show
would get five six seasons and we just
got two but I remember you know the head
called me and he was awesome love Keith
Cox and Keith was like Hey we're going
more female Centric and you know we're
not going to do the show anymore so I
was like ah okay and then I uh called
the other producer and the Creator and
the producer's like
C is can we find another home for it h i
don't know no one it just went away and
by the way I didn't get millions of
people going oh my God it was like you
know 300 300 people saying hey really
that sucks I like that you know but
I even then I had some hope going hey
you know this was a a pretty fun show
maybe but the fact that the response so
in a you know as much as we could sit
there and say I hate social media I hate
you know we all do it we're hypocrit and
we do it yet there's so many bad facets
of of social media but there are good
facets you know there good parts to it
and you know this without social media
this wouldn't have happened oh no
without a shadow of and I'm the same as
you I have hugely mixed feelings about
social media and I I again you know the
more you're in the spotlight the less
you want to use it is my feeling about
it like I just I want to be private um
protect things privately and I think
feel like going on social media you're
just leaving yourself open to anything
um and but at the same time I wouldn't
be here probably talking to you about
this thing right now if it hadn't been
for social media there are huge
positives to it yeah um but you know I
remember watching an interview with
David Boe back in 97 I think it was and
on BBC News night and he was talking
about the internet and he was talking
about what an incredibly amazing thing
it can be but also at the same time what
an incredibly what what a what a window
of Darkness it will open as well
absolutely and that's you know I'd say
the same thing about social media